my question for you is working with
family as someone that is a younger
brother what advice would you give me
bringing on my older brother to help me
with my content creating and media
production company family Dynamics are
real so you know even being the older
brother bringing in a younger brother
comes with a kind of baggage you've got
an extra one because the natural way of
things the older brother is going to
have all sorts of feelings even if he's
the most humble dude of all time there's
still some sort of like animalistic like
I'm the older brother kind of thing
going on the only way family businesses
ever work is when everyone in the
equation has empathy and compassion for
the other people's feelings so for you
personally a you have to have empathy
for your brother it's going to be a
challenge B for everyone listening you
have to love your family more than the
money see all of you are going to have
ego and feelings and you need to
understand that and calibrate it D no
matter how much you fight try to end
every night with like that was [__] up
but [__] it we're family let's like be
better tomorrow there's a lot there
those are just some things to keep an
eye out for